have aliens or any extraterrestrial
beings reached out to you as someone
who's a spokesperson have you had any
interaction not that long ago I had a
very much more credible than me friend
his name is Dave Foley from Kids in the
Hall and he was visiting me and he
started taking the piss at me being like
ah come see the UFO expert and don't see
a UFO that's pretty good not 45 seconds
later I say Dave look the up that
was the first time in my life I can say
that I ever saw a craft of unknown or
that was capable of doing something
unlike what I know is possible with our
known understanding of physics what we
really mean is straight up defying the
laws of physics yeah so a UFO will
appear and disappear okay great we have
stealth technology that can make that
appear to be the case for us but also
UFOs can appear to have Zero inertial
Effect these craft seem to be able to
move at 90° turns documented about
12,000 mph so not even the machine
itself should be able to handle that